if there is one topic that is usually in
the back of everyone's mind its money
according to a 2017 Gallup poll
healthcare costs debt inadequate wages
and college expenses are the biggest
financial challenge challenges families
say they face if you have questions
about how you're handling at all some
questions or some answers rather it can
be found in a new book the dumb thing
smart people do with their money
thirteen ways to write your financial
wrongs and joining us is a familiar face
to us the author CBS News business
analyst and certified financial planner
dr. Jill so I mean we know you're a
numbers girl but you start this book
with emotion I think that this is the
missing component because we are human
beings and we are driven by emotions and
when it comes to money there are two big
emotions that we always see there is
fear and there is greed and they can
pull us we also have these weird
cognitive biases that can lead us astray
and so the reason I wrote this book was
I felt like it's not all numbers we're
actually not programmed as human beings
to make really good long-term financial
decisions and hopefully if I can help
people avoid just one of these thirteen
errors they'll be better on let's talk
about one of the biggest ones financing
your child's college education I have
three of those it's very stressful how
do you navigate that I think the big
issue here is that we know a college
degree is really important and we want
our kids to be educated but we're seeing
families spend far too much money and
putting their own future at risk we
actually just got some research out last
week the fastest-growing segment of
student loan borrowers are those over
the age of 60 so what do we want to do
we want people to communicate with their
kids we want them to say here's how much
we can afford as a family we want them
to be really clear about that do that as
early as freshman year in high school we
want the kids to have a part in the
scholarship and grant
process and we want to remind everybody
by the way they're always lower-cost
options you don't have to go for the
most expensive school it's what you make
of that college experience so often
investing also obviously so big for
people and you say play your own game
what does that mean well look we always
hear about these rules of thumb around
investment advice that's kind of bunk
because you've really got to know
yourself as an investor and I have
pretty much like five outline tips that
people should keep in mind first is you
should not be investing unless you've
covered what I call the big three
meaning you've got to pay down your
outstanding debt you've got to have the
emergency reserve fund you've got to be
using your retirement account you've got
to max it to the best of your ability
now from there you want to create a
financial plan then you comes your asset
allocation I happen to like index funds
they're cheap so that's good we want you
to stick to the plan but you want to
revisit that plan when something goes on
in your life so it could be a birth a
death a divorce a marriage and we also
want you to just get in the habit of
revisiting it every few years there was
a fabulous party for you this past week
can we say we were very excited for you
in your new book but the highlight of
the party is was meeting your mom and
for her as well Susan I mean Anthony and
Susan what a star she was crushing on it
I was so happy to see her and we wish
you all the best with the book thank you
Jill thank you very much